al momento de conocer cuáles son las
principales noticias en materia
económica para américa latina y el resto
del mundo y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge comenzamos con una de las noticias
en materia económica que marcan las
jornadas sin lugar a dudas que tiene que
ver con el dato de inflación de eeuu así
de santiago y es que la inflación en
enero interanual allí fue del 75 por
ciento cinco décimas por encima de la de
diciembre estas cifras sin duda aumenta
la presión sobre la reserva federal para
subir los tipos de interés algo que los
funcionarios han dicho podría ocurrir el
próximo mes el dato de inflación es la
mayor subida interanual desde febrero de
1982 según la oficina de estadísticas
laborales los precios de los alimentos
subieron un 0,9 por ciento en enero de
2022 con respecto a diciembre esto es un
aumento del 7% con respecto a 12 meses
atrás mientras que los vehículos usados
subieron un 1,5 por ciento respecto al
mes pasado comprar un vehículo usado
cuesta 40% más que hace un año los
precios de los vehículos nuevos se
mantuvieron estables los precios de la
energía que incluye en santiago la
gasolina el crudo la electricidad y el
gas natural subieron en enero un 0 9%
respecto al mes anterior lo mismo que
los alimentos la secretaria del tesoro
de eeuu argumentó la subida con el
pronunciado cambio del gasto hacia los
bienes desde los servicios y los
bloqueos en la cadena de suministros
como efecto de la pandemia mientras
tanto el presidente de eeuu joe biden
pidió a los ciudadanos ser optimistas
escuchemos voy a trabajar como el
para bajar los precios de la gasolina lo
cual voy a hacer para asegurarme de que
sigamos fortaleciendo las cadenas de
suministro para reducir el costo de
energía y todos los demás bienes que
llegan a eeuu bueno seguimos en eeuu
jorge ahora pero para hablar de otro
tema porque el gobierno de joe biden
aprobó el plan del futuro eléctrico así
es el día de hoy abrió su programa de
inversión para instalar medio millón de
cargadores eléctricos en las carreteras
de ese país la idea de la administración
de bailén es potenciar la compra de
vehículos eléctrico y paliar un poco la
crisis climática actualmente las
carreteras de ese país cuentan con solo
puntos de cargas el gobierno ha dicho
que invertirá 7500 millones de dólares
en total para este proyecto de ellos 5
mil millones ya están disponibles para
ser transferidos a algunos estados
asimismo en una segunda ronda de
inversión de 2.500 millones de dólares
será destinado a subvenciones futuras
este paquete es parte del plan de
infraestructuras de 1,2 billones de
dólares aprobado por el congreso el
noviembre pasado y que se ha convertido
de alguna forma en la bandera económica
del gobierno o administración de uairén
cambiamos de tema el banco de méxico
aumentó la tasa de interés de qué se
trata esto jorge ha sido bueno el banco
5 como se conoce allá en méxico
argumentó esta decisión por la inflación
las tensiones geopolíticas globales y
los cambios en los mercados la tasa de
interés de referencia subió en 50 puntos
básicos para ubicarse en 6% y se
convierte en la segunda tasa más alta de
américa latina' la primera es la de
brasil luego de meses de llamar a la
inflación como un fenómeno transitorio
el banco de méxico admitió que las
presiones inflacionarias han sido de
magnitud y de mayor duración el banco
incrementó su pronóstico de inflación
para marzo entre el 67 y el 69 por
ciento la decisión del emisor es la
primera con victoria rodríguez ceja como
gobernadora recientemente ella fue
nombrada por el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador en el cargo la tasa de
interés interbancaria es la referencia
que usan los bancos para dar préstamos
de hipoteca tarjetas de crédito y
préstamos personales para algunos
analistas el aumento de la tasa de
interés y la inflación hacen más cara la
alimentación el vestir y las viviendas
de los mexicanos vamos que con los
indicadores que nos dicen hoy bueno
arrancamos con wall street que cerró en
rojo y su principal indicador el down
jones de industriales bajó un 1,47 por
ciento por la subida de la inflación
registrada en eeuu en enero las acciones
europeas terminaron ligeramente a la
baja por el aumento de los rendimientos
de los bonos y los débiles resultados de
la empresa francesa atos que
perjudicaron al sector de tecnología y
en américa latina la bolsa de buenos
aires cerró en positivo tras dos
jornadas consecutiva negativo cerramos
como siempre con la esperada cifra del
día cuál es la cifra es 35 por ciento 35
por ciento de pagos presenciales en
américa latina se hicieron sin contacto
en 2021 eso es el doble del 2020 la
adopción de esta tecnología fue liderada
por chile guatemala y costa rica con más
del 70 por ciento según visas gracias
porque por este completísimo repaso
hasta aquí la información económica en
france 24 sigan informando hace en el
resto de nuestra programación gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]